hi everybody good morning and thank you
for coming so I'm gonna get this talk
about iron and sequence labeling for a
document parsing and I'm gonna show how
do you implement that simple model to do
this intensive flow so first a small
thing we're informing from flex
pronounce them as you set and what we do
is we try to match people to jobs by
parsing their CVS their resumes building
up a profile that way and parsing
vacancies and then matching the exact
information with vacancies to those
people so that's when she document
parsing here in a title that's what I'm
talking about so just a quick check who
here does not know what 10th always it's
ok just ok so there's some people who
didn't work it out before everybody here
knows about the record in your network
is if you do know what the kicker neural
network is please raise your hand
ok so most people so this talk is one
they're not forgetful but I will
probably not explain like the basic
onion or it tends to tell too much so I
hope I am on the right level for this
crowd so the document pricing part this
is a city and its interchange rate small
fee to eat but what we want to do is we
want to take this kind of fun
then structure text I mean it's free
form but it's a semi structure and we
want to take this an output structure
information so we want to extract what
somebody's name so you see pedra it's a
first name from the pen is a last name
these are just sub strings document
tacked as being a name or last name or
as being a job title a data company to
extract people's work experience in
order to match them to a correct legacy
so the input IDs document to PDF or rich
text and normal
and we try to extract this information
so basically like I said these documents
are semi structured so we have to
sequence labeling problems one of them
is to extract these sections because
like I said you can't beat this document
but if I ask you where is this person's
personal information we can probably
point to the connect part because
everybody writes their resume is sort of
the same way same for work experience so
we expect these sections and then what
we're going to talk about today is how
do we take a section like this and
extract the relevant information so how
do we label this face as a date
office manager as a job title CTB flex
software and services VP as a company
and ADA which is sitting Netherlands as
a location so what we have here is a
sequence of words or a sequence of
tokens and we have a sequence of labels
namely the first three words are dates
the second the next two words are job
title the next word is nothing and then
there's a particular step our company so
that's what I mean with sequence
labeling if these days if you say
sequence labeling what do you think well
great no networks at least that's how I
work now the two most common problems
are named entity recognition which is
very similar to this it's recognizing
people's names or company names or
locations in running text and part of
speech tagging which is labeling words
as a verb noun feed on all these kind of
things so the way that you do this we
could know Network you have the sequence
of inputs then you have we could know
network layer your hidden layer and each
computational node is it's dependent on
the previous words or in some cases on
the next words this is like a very
global idea for like the two persons
that face their heads that didn't raise
the hands and ask
mikono networks but I'm going to assume
that this is sort of familiar it's
that's correct like yeah I see some
nothing yeah good and that that case
you're gonna have fun at this because
what I'm going to show is yeah what we
did we apply this kind of methods to our
phone because very similar to the
recognition and we developed some other
methods that are very specific to our
domain we are not going to talk about
that we just can't talk about how to
make a simple model that you can later
explain to your own domain and the old
way of doing this would be hidden Markov
models and conditional random fields and
that's what we used to apply and going
from those old-fashioned linguist models
like computational linguists area models
to this deep learning record no networks
we saw a good error reduction 30% less
errors we were very happy with that but
me being part of the team that
implements this the thing I'm really
happy with is that these moles are a lot
more flexible this hill mark moly like
you don't need used in one way but with
these no networks it's very easy to like
make like a multitask model or change
the architecture to have like different
types of input compared to the
conditional random fields they're just a
lot less which engineering this random
field should be just but all these rules
that might use in order to expect these
words and it would combine them writing
this kind of those manually just isn't
much fun and now you just give it more
data and it starts doing better and
that's a lot more fun because somebody
else takes the data for us okay so as
some qualitative differences if you take
like a hill Markkula it's very like
always taking the same words like power
plant theater it's seen that before
that's probably job title but that
doesn't really help you if you don't
know like where are you fitting this
power plant into and as we could know
network is a bit better at
learning to extract like sub phrases and
extracting from burning text so the old
mother might only see a job title if
there's a clear context these moles are
a bit better at like this ambiguous
context and also if you have something
like I was reporting to the general
manager general manager is not your job
title so our annotator wouldn't annotate
this job title and with enough data at
the network also against this kind of
context so in this talk we just had this
introduction we're gonna show how to
make a simple Alice TM sequence labeling
model quick sites not on how to serve it
if you want to do it in a hacky way and
then some of the challenges that you
have to face after you have this simple
mobile howdy HT are there to figure a
train and how do you solve like some of
the common problems with these models
I'm just gonna sort of go through the
problems and leave a team to solve it so
lsdm sequence labeling model who here
never heard lsdm before okay so that's
more people than I expected basically
it's short for a lone short-term memory
basically it's a recurrent neural
network the only difference is if you
have normal RNN you have this
multiplication on the previous states
this model is built slightly different
in such a way that you don't get this
big sequence of multiplications back
into time which makes it a bit less less
susceptible to this tension gradient
problem on Karla's block there's a
really nice example understanding
alastair networks I would say just
Google data if you want to know it has
really nice for citizens
surfer named entity recognition sequence
labeling
there were these bunch of like nice
papers and slides by the way you can
find the link in
the program I added this this morning
and what we are gonna do is show intense
flow how to implement a simple version
of the same kind of network that's in
these kind of papers so again and we had
this input sequence of word sequence of
labels so your training data looks like
this on the left you see these
normalized turbines we don't want every
day to be different entry into our
vocabulary so we normalize this and then
we see begin inside outside and coding
so the B is for begin at the beginning
of the days and I'm inside the date
inside the date beginning of the job
title inside the job title and always
for outside which means just anything
else so you create a lot of data in this
way and then we are going to fit that to
our network so it's this v double in the
back yeah good what do you need for this
dense flow Empire quite simple how do
you start
you start with some hyperparameters this
is some random example I just put in
some numbers so that we can get this
code to work what you also need is your
P change word embeddings just download
them use whatever is normally good for
your domain try a bunch of them here we
just have random embeddings that doesn't
work so well unless you know but what
you need is this embedding factor which
is the size of your vocabulary by your
embedding dimension so Ichiro in this
matrix is is a word factor for that
specific worthy of Kepler
so how do we start at this network I
showed you participate of us we need to
make some placeholders in tens flow so
for whoever said like I have never done
spell before it's basically a cough
competition highway you define
operations and you chain them to go
together and then in the end you want to
get your prediction so that outputs then
calculates back what it needs in order
to calculate its output and then the
really nice thing about it is it also
has outer differentiation so once you
calculate output you can get your
gradients towards the variables that you
specify and that means that you can
train a neural network with it so here
we have X which is a place all the
operations which mean that it's some
case where you can buy P data too and
this is a shape of like how big is your
batch by how big is our the sequence
length and you also give this secret
length because you have all these
sequences these sentences or these
documents of different lengths and you
pattern and in the end you don't want a
loss function to be affected by this
pattern characters so we use the sequin
tank information to mask that padding
out later and then since dense flower is
really built for it making your networks
it has all these really handy operations
such as embedding the problem basically
just be places Fe index in your input
vector which are just the word index
into your vocabulary by the
corresponding word vector so you end up
with a batch size by your maximum length
by embedding size 10 so if the sudden
using like medium clear just raise your
hands
then we can do some take questions
everything so just to show how the graph
looks if you visualize this meeting is a
virtual box it's not very quick the way
you see here is this embedding tensor
and the inputs words as if it's length
and here this is a variable which is
just holding that big embedding vector
so how do we define a simple SEM network
again tense flow to the rescue you just
have a basic lsdm cell and if you're
doing these kind of things these days
what you want to do is you want to have
to drop out to it which is a technique
for for training set works I think it's
best not to go into it now but I just
added it to this example so that when
you want it you get a bit of a better
like less of fitting Network so what
you'll notice here this basically see
himself the only thing that you need to
give it is how big is its hidden state
and the other thing you'll notice here
is that this is not connected to the
network yet so this P SVM cell is just
defining the structure of yourself now
if you want to actually connect this to
the network
I want to do as you want to do one RN
and that reads text left white one RN n
that which text writer left and I can
catenate the outputs of those
because if I see some job title
somewhere and then there's a clear
company name after that then it's good
to know that the next word is a company
name so this is probably the end of the
job title so here we just define that
cell using a function that we defined in
the previous code snippet and intense
flow has several ways of defining Arnon
my favorite is this one by directional
dynamic Arnon so there's a dynamic and
aesthetic version a static version means
that you have this unmould network over
the entire sequence length dynamic
version means that's implemented as a
while loop which will go over the tokens
depending on the length of your sequence
so it will skip dependent characters so
it's bit costlier to define but like
when you're running it it's more
efficient so I'd suggest this one or the
multi-layer version of this
mmm everything else here oh yeah one
thing you need to know is that you need
to give it a scope so tense flow is
organized in named scopes which
basically means like any variable and
they need one scope why not share with
other scopes this function uses this
Dennett scope which means that if you
use it multiple times you end up reusing
variables by accident usually somebody
put in a card for that but if you get
these errors about oh I can't do this
because this is already defined but we
use it's not set it - you just need to
pass it let's go explicitly and then in
the end here you see we concatenate
those two by DF of concat any questions
so far
all right so now we're going to make
this network we inputs the word
embeddings that we made in the second
snippet and for the second layer we just
say like oh the input for the next layer
is the output of this first layer and
that way you are stacking these
bi-directional layers so like you see
here the embeddings in a secret length
at input for this bill as here layers
bi-directional layers and the input of
the second layer is the output of the
first layer this is going to cooperate
inside this layer you see there is this
forward and backwards operation
and the way that there's backward thing
as a finance just like he refers the
input sequence and then you apply it
exactly the same cell and then you
refers it back
okay so we are at the States we fit in
the sequence of characters as an output
here we get this concatenated factors
for each token now we want to label for
each to open right so we have this
basically a feature vector and you want
to it into a label so how do we make
these predictions it's quite simple
really if you just treat each token
independently so each word independently
you just say like oh I want some
probabilities for each class for each
token so what you can do is just a
linear combination of this and filter
through softmax function so layer so
tense is just a single feed-forward
layer if you don't specify activation
function it's a linear activation so
basically this is some weight matrix
times your feature vector plus your bias
the only thing here is if you're working
with these islands which have this bed
size by secret length matrix but you
want to apply this to each word
separately either to be shaped it's in
such a way that you have one long
sequence of words by this feature factor
size and then you apply it and then you
just shape it back and forth at all you
know as Oh what's this original size of
this matrix
and if you apply some toxic waste this
you get your normalized probabilities
but if you just want your predictions
you just take the highest of these
locates questions
okay so you have your outputs
predictions but now you want to train on
this and like I said tense flow allows
is gradient based training it has a
bunch of gradient minimizes initialized
specified like atom that also likes to
castigate in the sense all these kind of
goodness but we don't want it trained on
these predictions because if you take
the gradient of your necks
it couldn't be pretty unhappy right so
we have multi-label classification
problem so what you have is a
probability for each class and you have
your two probabilities for each classes
mainly is the class that you want it to
be your example in your data has this
assigned class the probability for that
you should be one for build for the rest
should be zero you just want to have a
smooth function that you can train it on
so what you say so we take the cosine
speed between these two distributions
and then tense flow has this parse
softmax exactly that love it
what this means is that the sparse part
is just your labels can be the labels as
just a class number instead of having to
have this one coding coding so this is
scarier than it looks it's actually not
sparse operation it's just labels label
format
next like I said at the start we don't
on these petting characters to influence
a loss so use these stupid lengths to
make a mask to mask out the padding
characters and then you apply it this
way and then you take your mean of
alternates no questions over
so what we do here you pick some
optimizer and some new animates yeah I
just take karate constants but probably
you want to pick this carefully and tune
it if you have a look at this graph
yeah
right this one right so your input
sequences is like each row in that
matrix is one sequence and some
sequences are longer than other
sequences so the shorter sequences you
put them all and say matrix a you just
end up petting them with zeros all right
these predictions make some prediction
for the spreading characters you don't
want those predictions to be taken into
account in your loss function so it just
mask them out and then you take me
so one nice thing you can do here
clean up your graph this defines your
loss function based on the log it's in
your sequence length so you can do the
sequence masking and then this basically
is connected to everything because it
calculates gradients for all your
variables for example here we see this
dense layer it has your bias any weights
factor both of those gets ya this is
probably too small but the thing I'm
pointing here is the Train step which is
feeding variances okay so
all right so basically like
inside/outside begin if I have begin job
title and inside job title for this as
multi-label classification from you just
treat them as two separate labels that
way to begin can have like yeah you can
learn about context and this just like
it's just a label number so if begin job
titles well inside your tights probably
too outside might be label manatee and
then you just compare this that depends
on your learning problem but like so we
have a bunch of models that all predict
specific phases for work an experience
it's like five different types of phases
so then you have 10 labels plus outside
this 11 usually it ranges between
anywhere from like six to 20 or
something so it's not like really really
large amount of labels it's quite
amenable number of classes
okay so we have to supposed to find how
the Train is intense flow one thing you
might want to know is like Oh how's my
loss decreasing the examples I was
showing where you could see the corphish
with station let's go ten support it's
really nice it can also show graphs so
with each batch I want to show my loss
function it's a one line intense flow
and that's basically the whole reason
why my team is using turns flow because
it's so nice to visualize acting
intensive art so let's say we make some
venom examples with venom output we make
a thousand examples we sample random
sequence lengths and then we make some
random examples of item outputs of that
length so this is not something that you
would normally do this again random
stuff to get some example to work in my
notebook in VirtualBox which is slow so
that's why I didn't take a look at it
[Music]
but if you want to train something like
this you have these two tier ways you
have your very to sequent length you
have your way with your number of
examples by their length and you have
your way with the labels for each token
you make a generator for this here it
just yields a batch of input sequences a
batch of sequent lengths and a batch of
your training labels and if this was
called oh yeah what you see here we make
a tensor flower session where graph is
already initialized in this session
that's what all the other coders
building is graph one thing to do is
this global variation Eliezer what that
does is you have all these variables
defined like your weight variables in
your lsdm and in this dense layer you
just initialize it to their initial
State another nice thing about transfer
is that many of these things are defined
such way that the initial state makes
sense for training so you didn't see me
specify them anywhere then what we want
to do is we want to write out these
those features in this case you also
want to save your model probably and
then we just loop over the number of
epochs and we loop over all these
batches so we have the inputs the length
the labels and you create a feedback for
your for your model so in a fairly first
cell you saw as defining these
placeholders this is how you fill this
place always so X here is still the
variable pointing to the tensor and
expect is just this numpy array that you
feel in
then you on this train step and in our
case we also have on this train so me
because we want to see it in tens flow
and you just do this for all the badges
that you have and even though these are
random examples with random outputs you
can see it's still more than happy to
just memorize all your examples and the
bus function so I would say like if
you're following along with this at home
later if if you're making like mistakes
in your graph just debug it here make
sure that you visualize as much as
possible here
so that you see how your training is
doing compared to what we were doing
before with like putting these things in
our own log files and making own look
for imagine everything dense fluid such
a big improvement over that and not just
because it's helped us get rid of all
the environments and see errors let's go
back here
no you don't need to in this case like
you mean like the hidden States for in
the previous now you don't need to
because when you do the forward
computation it doesn't use that state it
has a zero states which you don't need
to initialize it does I don't see your
question anything else before we jump to
like something very different after that
we can talk about that's just after the
thing I just asked the question scan at
the ends of it yeah well I'll be my my
now get back to it okay so if you're
like us and you have this huge pearl
libraries and you need to integrate
these models into this there's a really
nice dense flow surfing likely you
probably want to use that in order to
surf your model but if you want to hack
it into your full pipeline and you don't
want to implement GRP see info just
build a flask surf around it's the main
thing to know is if you use the save
model formats oh I can select X here
like I could in the book the tens
Falcons a predictor in sake model it
gives you a very simple API to get
predictions back from your model so it's
really as simple as that this is a
working example two flask surfer surfing
this model that he just raids but if
you're putting stuff in productions and
you do not have this old pipeline really
you stand for certain so let's say you
have a sequence labeling problem you
take this example and you get everything
right and you train it on your data why
is it not performing as well as you
hoped it would
one thing is tuning like I said learning
rate and optimization algorithm is very
important which word fact that you use
the Avanti to newirth factors themselves
how big is your state size I mean you
want it to be bigger at least than the
dimensionality of your word embeddings
because if you're thinking about
classifying tokens and you have this
embedding space and you want to make
tokens separable in its base you
probably want to have one in order to
transform the space in such a way that
these things are separable
next thing is like if you have a domain
like we have you're probably gonna have
multilingual documents or milf limit
sequences so you want to do something
clever in order to handle debt if you
just use your Dutch word embeddings on
this English text you're not going to be
a happy most of the examples that I gave
the the papers that I linked to a lot of
them use commission venom-filled as
outputs without so basically instead of
treating each token as a separate
classification you want to get the most
optimal sequence of classifications for
your sequence so you can still basically
use the output of this network as the
potentials for your COF and just that
the probability of going from one class
to the other class tends flows as this
building it's an exercise for the reader
in this case and if you want to do stuff
like I said where you want to get these
sections out in this case you have
sequence of lines you want to classify
lines but you need some liner betting
one option is to just put in another
layer of ireland's which go of each line
and then like to mix pulling or
something and get output from that and
feed that to the following blsm there
you can use completion on neural
networks or you could just like take the
mean over all the words something like
that but it really all these things have
a big impact on your yeah your output
accuracy so if you want to know like how
the attacks on all of these things look
at our career website and if there's any
questions I'll get back first to yours
but first thank you for
so first question do you want to repeat
it in the mic maybe it's just now do you
have a mic sorry for all the people on
YouTube I didn't thank you very much for
the talk were nice to see something
clicks that people use it in practice in
production very encouraging inspiring
and what about I spotted you don't use
this data API from tensorflow which is
much more efficient you use generator
what about performance of training so
what about size do you use and how do
you put these days into the like what is
the performance of putting this data
into GPU alright first off if we quickly
scope here if you are doing this on GPU
so we had this whole infrastructure for
a twenty or in markups and conditional
random fields which is all CPU based and
we wanted to be used at infrastructure
so most this is actually trade on CPUs
if you want to do this on GPUs don't use
this Alice TM cell use the Korean
variants in that case you definitely
want to use the data API to feed inputs
and you want to just tune your batch
size in order to get maximum utilization
your V give you and you probably want to
try the word embeddings to CPU so that's
two Nets like try try the bad choice
because it's video Bennett's on your
hardware and like for the CPU we use
like between 22 and honest 28 or
something doesn't matter so much for GPU
it is very important just a really quick
question so thanks so talk
I saw your link for the slides but is
there a link to the notebook as well
probably not like current leader policy
it's still getting refute hopefully
later but maybe not okay so you
mentioned you got like 10 to 30%
reduction in error so can can you can um
basically break it down like in terms of
you know which classes it works for best
like job titles you know which one of
these was was better improved by by your
technique and how much training data
that he needs and how did you collect
the training date okay so as tight as a
second on the first how much training
data do you need these are very long
sequences with a lot of classes on them
so there's a lot of information in them
so not that much like a few thousand
documents was enough so that's nice
thing about the secrets is if you have a
lot of labels there's still a lot of
information in them how it work best
yeah best is to these numbers don't say
everything you want to look at those
positive examples maybe so what I showed
for job title those were really good
improvements we didn't notice that there
was a certain pattern in for which
fields that work better than others but
yeah maybe come find me afterwards later
well time for one more question thank
you
you mentioned the CRF that quite briefly
at the end I wasn't sure does that get
trained jointly with the RNN or are
there just two separate modules yeah
tensorflow has like this imputation for
EMF so better you design the transition
probabilities as well as the network
that's giving you the potentials so that
range only you just need to use a
different loss function all right thank
you for a great talk
[Applause]